this educational video
brought to you by lab roots will focus
on exoplanets and the suggestion of
are we unique in the universe is there
life elsewhere in our galaxy or in the
universe
lab roots is the leading professional
networking website designed to connect
the scientific world
leveraging a myriad of unique features
helping users discover
meaningful collaborations across
geographic boundaries
and fields of expertise providing
educational tools such as webcasts are
part of lab roots ongoing effort
to help science and technology
professionals better communicate and
disseminate information among each other
effectively educating users on the
latest discoveries and innovations in
their area of expertise
for hundreds of years scientists have
believed that planets existed outside of
our solar system
but until recently we did not have the
technology to discover them or know if
they were similar to planets within our
own solar system
scientists have discovered planets
outside of our solar system
they are called exoplanets or extrasolar
planets
the first exoplanet was discovered in
1995.
this was a giant planet orbiting around
a nearby star
called 51 pegasi since then
the technology for discovering
exoplanets has vastly improved and
allowed us to discover
thousands of them there are several
techniques being used to discover these
exoplanets
radial velocity certain stars are
affected by the gravity of the planets
that orbit them
and will wobble from this effect through
doppler spectroscopy
scientists can detect this wobble it is
easier to spot this effect with
low mass stars and the gravitational tug
that planets put on them
transit method this method detects
planets when they cross
or transit in front of the star and the
amount of light changes as seen from the
star
there is a high rate of false positives
using this method and it needs to be
confirmed using radial velocity
or some other method however it is
easier to gauge the size of the planet
and the atmosphere around it using the
transit method
timing variations a planet that is
orbiting a star can create variations of
timing for orbiting periods of other
planets that orbit the same star
this can confirm the presence of one or
more planets but doesn't give us much
other information about them
gravitational lensing this technique is
used if there is a star in front of
another star
and the gravitational field of the star
in front creates a lens
and magnifies the light from the star
behind it and any planets orbiting that
star
this method is useful for finding
planets around stars in the center of
our galaxy
where there are a multitude of
background stars to create the lensing
effect
direct imaging this is a very difficult
way to discover exoplanets
planets reflect light from the star that
they orbit when they are close to the
star they are lost in the glare
when they are far away from the star
they do not reflect much light
if the planet is very large larger than
jupiter it can give off a significant
infrared signature that makes it more
visible
astronomers can use a coronagraph to
block out the light from the star
and make it more visible as well the
kepler mission was designed by the
united states and nasa to look at a very
small portion of our part of the milky
way galaxy
to find exoplanets and specifically to
find earth-sized exoplanets that orbit
the habitable region of the parent star
and then to extrapolate that information
to determine how many billions of stars
in our milky way galaxy
have these potentially habitable
earth-sized planets
as of january 1st 2014 the kepler
mission has found
3568 candidate planets
1055 are confirmed and reside in 801
planetary systems most of the planets
discovered are jupiter size or larger
and consist mostly of gas a small
percentage
one plus percent are earth size and our
rocky inconsistence
there is a larger percentage that are
also rocky but much larger than earth
and referred to as super earths
the vast majority of these planet
discoveries used the radial velocity
method
through the discovery of exoplanets the
interest in finding habitable planets
with the possibility of some form of
life has increased significantly
the interest lies in finding planets
orbiting in the habitable or goldilocks
zone of the parent star
not too hot which is too close to the
star and not too cold
which is too far away from the star the
habitable zone
where there could be an atmosphere and
liquid water on the surface
and therefore the possibility for some
form of life to exist
based on the kepler project and other
related studies
scientists estimate that there are as
many as 40 billion earth-sized planets
in our milky way galaxy
the likelihood or probability that some
form of life exists within our galaxy
is huge astronomers estimate that there
are hundreds of billions of galaxies in
the universe
and that most of them are common to our
milky way
is there life out there what do you
think
you